[Music]
Raja I am so excited to be here with you
today thank you for joining me thank you
so much for having me I'm just so
excited to be here as well of course so
I want to start tell me about what invis
aware does of course so invis aware
creates jewelry and accessories with
safety technology hidden inside like
this necklace I'm wearing there's a
button thank you so much nobody ever
suspects it's a safety device but if you
click this backside two times it will
immediately Alert five emergency
contacts to let them know you're in an
emergency and need help and it can also
optionally contact
911 wow that is impressive in such a
little device thank you so much nobody
would ever know it's crazy so what was
the inspiration for you for starting
this company oh my gosh it was so crazy
never in a million years did I ever
think I would start a company I actually
was only 21 years old at the time I was
in college doing a double major in
electrical engineering and computer
science when I had a scary situation I
was at an event with some friends and I
thought to myself maybe I should ask
someone to walk with me to my car and
then I immediately told myself I was
being paranoid cuz there was probably
less than a block away I didn't want to
inconvenience anyone so I said my
goodbyes and I started walking back to
my car as I was about halfway between
where the car is and the event is an SUV
full of guys drove by they rolled down
window and started yelling super
inappropriate comments first I kind of
rolled my eyes cuz things like this
sadly happen to us women all the time
absolutely I continue walking the car
stops and one of the four guys starts to
get out oh my God I had my phone with me
but what do you do you can't really look
at them and be like hey leave me alone
I'm just going to call the police tell
them where I am what the emergency is oh
and please don't like please don't move
me for 7 to 8 minutes that's unrealistic
I ended up running as quickly as I could
go got to my car safely and thankfully I
wasn't hurt that night but for the next
hour and a half I was shaking
uncontrollably cuz all I could think
about is I could have been that news
story you see on the news I could have
been that true crime podcast that we all
listen to so nonchalantly I started
looking for safety devices to buy to
protect myself and the women I care
about but everything was a big ugly
panic
button you know what my grandma says
about those things she says she'd rather
and not be able to get up and to be seen
wearing one of them ex my family says
the same thing oh my gosh so it blew my
mind I was like how is nobody creating
them in jewelry and vises come in
necklaces bracelets keychains Fitness
bands and scrunchies wow that's
incredibly scary and you're right it's
something pretty much every woman I know
has faced seriously how did it feel for
you then to take it from like an idea in
your head then to actually going and
being an entrepreneur creating the
product like how did you feel making
that jump thank you so I never really
imagined it would become what it is
today it actually originally started as
a class project so I was doing my senior
year Capstone at the University of
Massachusetts LEL and I told my best
friend his name is Ray I said why don't
we create safety devices for a project
and then at the end of this we can have
them for ourselves and our loved ones
and he was like that's a great idea my
sisters always call me and they're
always nervous and they ask him to stay
with him on the phone while they're
walking back to their car he's like I'd
love give them this so originally we're
creating them for ourselves and our
loved ones to make sure they're safe but
then we started hearing so many sad
stories from sexual assault survivors
and it's actually horrific studies show
one out of every five women is sexually
assaulted at some point in her lifetime
W This is highly unacceptable and needs
to change so we ended up entering the
entrepreneurship competition at umle and
we took home first place for an
Innovative technology solution
and then we both graduated and we
decided to decline some prestigious job
opportunities I actually turned down an
opportunity with Google I always joke
I'm like don't tell your parents you're
declining a job with Google they're
going to think you lost your mind were
they a little upset or how did they take
it oh my gosh at first they were shocked
it of course takes a lot of money to
develop a safety product or a tech
company in general so we knew we needed
to raise at least
$150,000 to bring the product to Market
and it was actually really sad my mom
and dad at the beginning they were like
Raja like we don't come from money like
where are you going to get that you need
to take the job at Google like do you
know how much money you'd be making as a
software engineer in
California and I just couldn't do it all
I could think about was how am I going
to live my life doing nothing about
these horrific statistics and what if I
do raise the funding and one day this
product saves someone's life then it
will all happen extremely worth it I did
it and I declined that opportunity and
it was by far one of the best decisions
of my life amazing now tell me about
that fundraising Journey how did you go
about it and then how much have you
raised today of course so we originally
started off thinking we only needed
$150,000 to develop the product and
everyone was like nobody's going to give
two 21 year olds
$150,000 well we actually raised close
to $3 million to bring the product to
Market and to also Market it amazing how
who are some of your investors and how
did you kind of convince them to jump on
board oh my gosh so at first we got a
ton of NOS I kid you not we probably got
80 to 90 Nos and so many people were
saying things like oh you're just too
young you've never started a company
before but a lot of our investors are
actually Angel Investors in the Boston
area and one thing they all have in
common is they're all parents who
immediately understood the mission of
the company oh that's so cool thank you
now talking about um competitors cuz you
said you know the old way to do it
everything was clunky big Panic buttons
right um how do you set yourself apart
from competitors who are doing similar
things in the space as you and who would
you consider to be your biggest
competitors great question so when we
started the company we had zero
competitors it was all the big ugly
Panic buttons which to be honest with
you they target seniors they're not even
really going after young women and then
shortly after a couple years later two
young women out of Harvard they were
actually both sexual assault survivors
thought of the same concept so they
decided to create jewelry as well it's a
great company called flare um but we
recently announced that my business
partner Ray and I acquired all of the
assets of flare so now invis and flare
are the largest two companies in the
space Oh that's fantastic how did you go
about your first big acquisition oh my
gosh it was incredibly exciting and it
was such a huge learning opportunity I
keep joking with everyone that I feel
like I got an honorary law degree now
was months and months of legal work and
it was so exciting we are kind of going
after two different Target markets with
both companies so with Flare we're
targeting more younger college aged
women it's a bracelet that's a very
Sleek design and then with invis we're
going after more parents and it's more
of a premium product invisor actually
has a really amazing partnership with
ADT the number one name and security oh
very cool thank you so much okay that
makes sense thank you so talk to me
about the scale of your business how is
your sales growth bin how many customers
do you have it's been incredible we
actually have sold over a 100,000
devices and we've surpassed over $15
million in Revenue which has been such a
huge milestone for us fantastic what
would it take for you to sell your
company then and is that your goal or do
you want to keep acquiring that's a
great question we would definitely be
open to an acquisition opportunity if it
would help us reach millions of women
and protect even more people it would
definitely have to be the right partner
who would support our mission to create
a safer world but we also truly believe
that we have the opportunity to become a
unicorn as well we've done over 15
million dollar in sales and a lot of
that has been Word of Mouth marketing
and happy customers telling each other
about it so we're actually considering
raising another round of financing a
series a to help scale our growth very
cool now talk to me about those
customers what are some of the most
impactful stories that you're able to
share with me that people have shared
with you of course so sadly we get a lot
of people that purchase a product after
a sexual assault has happened and it's
really touching I try not to get
emotional over it but it's just so sad
how often these things happen and we're
trying to do our best to convince people
to buy the product before they need it
not after a situation has happened and
that's been really challenging because
you don't want to scare people but at
the same time it's such a real problem I
had a call just the other day with a
young woman she said she saw our product
on Tik Tok and she said that she thought
it was really great and it was amazing
and then she actually was a model she
went to a cast call and the guy ended up
drugging and raping her which was just
just so so horrible and she said to me
the whole time I was getting raped I was
thinking I wish I had bought that
product and that maybe I wouldn't have
had to endure this trauma if I had
bought her necklace and it's just so sad
I just wish I had the funding to
distribute them to every single woman
for free to help prevent that and Men
cuz things like this sadly happen to men
um but every single day we hear real
life stories of people who are buying
the product and have peace of mind we've
had a lot of domestic violence survivors
too who have personally wrot written us
handwritten notes saying thank you and
that they can finally sleep for the
first time in years CU they have our
device um we've saved a young woman in a
serious car accident we've had some
realtors that had some almost attacks
that they were able to be proactive and
call for help that's terrifying oh my
gosh it really is how do you think about
you know your business we're in a time
where it's being a woman is so political
right now it really is how do you think
about your product at a time when it's
not only scary for women you know um in
these situations that you're describing
but also politically and and we're
talking about like our rights that are
on the line how are you thinking about
that as you're doing your company gosh
it's unbelievable we're trying to do our
best to give back as much as we can and
donate to nonprofits that help combat
our mission and help support women in
general and we try and partner with as
many other women entrepreneurs as well
so we recently partnered with a company
called night cap so the young woman I
was telling you about it's sadly so
common for people to get roofied or
drugged before an assault takes place so
we're trying to support other women
entrepreneurs we partnered with a young
woman named Shir she is actually
featured on night cap she makes a
scrunchie that goes on top of your drink
to protect it from getting roofed I've
heard of that oh my gosh it's such a am
con interesting okay now going back back
when you were younger what would you
tell yourself the day before you
launched your company that you wish you
knew now oh my gosh so many different
things I think the biggest advice would
be to believe in yourself so many people
will tell you all of the reasons that
you could fail I can't tell you the
number of people who thought Ray and I
were out of our minds to decline Google
and to decline all of these prestigious
job opportunities people would say
things like nine out of 10 businesses
fail you shouldn't even try like take
that job it's you're crazy to decline it
and all I could think about is well who
says we're not going to be the one out
of 10 and we actually were which is so
exciting that's amazing thank you so
much but the other thing I would say is
if you don't build your dreams someone
else is going to hire you to build
theirs that's one of my favorite that's
a very good line and that actually leads
me to my next question is there like a
business rule that you and Ry follow no
matter what all the time it's always
customer satisfaction I would say we
truly built our company on hearing the
feedback and advice from our customers
listening to what they like trying to
innovate and fix things that they don't
like and say customer satisfaction is
probably our biggest priority and then
the second one would be to surround
yourself with people that are a lot more
intelligent than you so we have done a
good job in finding really great
advisers and mentors who've already been
there and have been built extremely
successful companies and we're so
grateful for all their support now
talking about the future what is next
for you what future exciting things do
you have in the pipeline in 2024 we're
continuing to innovate our app as much
as possible to add new features we
recently added video streaming
capabilities voice activation chat
activity tracking and then in the future
I'll tell you actually one of my goals
I'd love to hear it I'd love to partner
with some well-known jewelry companies
such as Kendra SC she is probably one of
the most aspiring women and we'd love to
put our technology in those well-known
Brands to help get more access the
millions of women who love her jewelry
that's really smart I love that thank
you so going back to your funding
Journey then talk to me a bit about as a
woman going into a male-dominated VC
field and trying to pitch this female
Centric product how was that for you and
was it hard to to convince people to
take a chance on you it definitely was
not easy we sadly got so many disgusting
comments while we were raising money I
had one investor look me dead in the
eyes and say that he doesn't think women
care about their safety after I
specifically told him the horrific
statistics and shared that we had done
over a million dollars in Revenue wow um
but we actually had a really horrible
story happen where we were doing a
friendly shark tank pitch competition to
teach young entrepreneurs how to raise
funding in the entire panel four were
men one was a woman the woman started by
saying that she loves the product wishes
she had one when she was in college and
can think of so many different use cases
the next guy looked at me and said that
his wife never ever complained about her
safety and that because of that he
doesn't think there's a need for this
product there was about 200 women
sitting in the audience and they started
booing him and
then for that crazy I said with all due
respect sir I think the women in the
audience would have to disagree and he
responded by saying well I'm going to
ask my wife cuz I've never heard of this
oh my God it was just so unbelievable
that's so hard the next judge decided to
take the cake so I started the company
with a male co-founder he's my best
friend and he looks at me and asks if I
had ever been intimate with my
co-founder that's completely
inappropriate can you believe that I was
appalled wow I walked off the stage and
I just completely felt mortified the CEO
of the organization was really
incredible he issued an apology he
personally called me he said they
promised to do better and to put a
gender equal panel next year during this
friendly competition wow but the really
funny thing that happened is there was a
gentleman by the name of Matt sitting in
the audience and Matt called me two
weeks later he said hi Raja my name is
Matt I was sitting in the audience I
witnessed everything that happens I
managed the finances of a very wealthy
woman her name is Michelle and when I
got back I told Michelle exactly what
happened and Michelle said that she
faced similar discrimination when she
was Raising funding for her first
company he said Michelle would like to
have a conversation with you and is
interested in investing in invis oh my
God I couldn't believe it I had a really
great conversation with Michelle she
told me about so many situations where
she faced or her loved ones faced where
they worried about their personal safety
and then she said you know what I want
to repeat your experience with that
Shark Tank presentation we did a ton of
due diligence she said she wants to
invest but that she won't decide how
much she wants to invest until after she
puts all the sales directors in her
company on this friendly shark tank
panel and I redo the pitch I said
absolutely I would love that and then
this time when they were giving the
feedback every single woman on the panel
started off by sharing a story of when
she personally feared for her safety wow
Michelle called me afterwards and she
said she originally was considering
investing half a million dollars in
invisor but after talking to all of the
women judges she put on the panel she
decided to double her investment and
invest $
million that's amazing isn't that
incredible and she wanted to issue a
statement basically because she had
faced the same thing when she was
Raising funding good for you turning a
negative into a positive that was so
incredible I never would have imagined
that would have turned out after that
horrible situation
wow one last question for you what would
you want your legacy to be I would
really hope to change the horrific
statistics surrounding sexual assault
it's honestly unacceptable how many
women are assaulted and that's only the
reported numbers that I shared with you
earlier really hope we can prevent these
situations from happening that is an
amazing goal thank you so much Raja
thank you so much for having me it was
so great chatting with you good luck
with your journey thank you so
much
[Music]
[Applause]